but like with with the exclusion
everything I just I guess from what I've
seen from BLM Advocates the protests the
movement and even the organization which
is far to the left of what the general
BLM actual marcher believes I just I
guess I just don't see these
exclusionary Tendencies even if we were
to believe there was an exclusionary
element here outside of the mere
language of the movement
um there are racialized elements of this
disparity that can't be solved just with
class Solutions it's like um it's like
if you if a hundred years ago you put
all the black folk in section A and all
the white folk in section B and then 100
years later you're like oh I'm really
sorry about that so anyway people in
section a uh make half as much as people
in section B I'm sorry that's the law no
race mentioned just what neighborhood
are you born in and the bread lining and
the distribution of wealth has reflected
a distinct racialized oppression in this
country that I think we can solve with
race neutral policies but we must
acknowledge that it exists but black
lives matter isn't advocating for race
neutral policies they're advocating for
racial policies like racialization like
so in in uh for instance in Seattle
they're doing you know POC and non-poc
separate events at the University of
Michigan we saw the non-poc in the like
literal neo-segregation popping up in
response to this movement and and the
most notable thing and shocking thing to
me was California's proposition uh I
believe it's prop 16 repeal prop 209
which would strike the Civil Rights
language from their constitution I want
to be specific about those two so the
POC non-poc separate thing this is
I don't really think that this is like
an official BLM thing that's being
pushed for I think that's woke crap as
well by the way I don't think that you
can make an argument for it provide a
safe space whatever I don't think it
does what it's supposed the organizers
of black lives matter say these things
sure yeah but when we're talking about
like what BLM wants I don't mean like
these little events or soirees which may
have like these weird elements that are
kind of like misappropriated woke
culture what I mean is like broadly how
are we fixing this multi-trillion dollar
economic Gap that we have and when it
comes to the California thing I'm mixed
on this the reason they're doing that is
because the language of their law
prevents them from implementing
affirmative action the same way other
states in this country do it's just
optically it looks terrible like wow you
know uh uh California gone so woke that
they're getting rid of civil rights and
it looks terrible and I recognize that
if I don't know if it's supported if it
if it was a civil rights if it was a if
it was an affirmative action Amendment
as they claim it was then they would
have amended it to add language
protecting affirmative action instead of
stripping all civil rights from the
Constitution well they I mean they still
are um they're still they have to adhere
of course to national law regarding that
would require Federal intervention so
California is Paving the way for
internally so for instance uh California
legalized medicinal marijuana when it
was federally illegal and then
complained when the DEA would go in and
raid if California strips away the Civil
Rights language thanks to unanimous
support from Democrats and federal
Democrats then they're going to start
implementing racist and racial
segregation policies Statewide and then
a specific programs saying no to this
race and no to that race I mean if
you're talking about affirmative action
we can start with that institutional
racism outright do you think that
affirmative action is an inherently
wrong thing I think it's an
Institutional racism sure whether you
think it's wrong personally for me yes
absolutely and that's because I come
from a mixed race family so I've already
experienced being a second-class citizen
from from uh groups aligned with
whatever you want to call it
intersectionality or whatever it's it's
not fun it's I believe it flies in the
face of everything my my uh grandparents
fought for in terms of civil rights they
were a mixed race couple it was illegal
they faced prison time over this and
they had to flee several States because
of it
my mom was born before civil rights and
lovingby Virginia as an illegal person
like wasn't allowed to exist in this
country because of miscegenation laws
they're bringing these things back I
don't think they're bringing back
miscegenation no no no they're bringing
back I'm talking about the the the
they're stripping away the civil rights
law They're bringing back segregation I
I really given the um the reasons and
the unilater or the multilateral support
that this proposition of received the
idea to me that they're removing a
specific California set of policies
um to imp to to then become the most
racist state in in the in the nation
even though they're equally beholden
because let's be clear once California
removed these laws they're going to be
at the same point a lot of other states
in this country are other states in this
country also rely on a set of federal
protections when it comes to
discrimination in workplaces and what
have you California is going to be an
equal standing with them I think we're
being really uncharitable when we assume
that they're doing this as part of a
step one to like you know bring back
like racism in this country well well it
it is I mean well it depends on whether
or not you think affirmative action
something which is already done at a
bunch of others yeah it is racist sure
but if that's the case then let's not
pretend that California is like
backsliding past the Civil Rights
Movement let's just acknowledge that
they're I guess awkwardly moving towards
the implementation of policies that a
bunch of other states already have I
think I'm 50 50 on affirmative action I
think that's like conceptually it
disgusts me you know but on the other
hand like if you think about it in
certain neighborhoods of like Los
Angeles for example where I grew up if
you get like a College admission or a
college um yeah like um
application sorry from a black person a
white person you don't know anything
about these two people apart from what
they send you statistically the black
person has had to work harder because
their neighborhoods on average are way
worse same with worse schooling there's
actually a really good point uh it's
really funny when we hear what was this
there was something about they wanted to
do they want to do blind hiring because
they felt like names were I I saw a post
in the Facebook actually people were
advocating it was leftists saying we
should get rid of you know your names
and your your address and let people
choose based on what their you know uh
what their Merit is and blah blah well
they didn't say Merit but that's a
general idea you put an application
their concern is that white culture that
you know or or mainstream American
culture favors anglicized names
therefore people at a disadvantage they
actually found there was a study that
found the opposite and it's actually
exactly what you said if you take a
person uh on statistically on average a
white person's more likely to have
family wealth more likely to have to
grow up in a wealthier suburb less
likely to have encounters with police
for a variety of reasons and then
they're going to have a resume that says
I went to this school into this school I
went to this college whereas people in
the black community Latino Community are
going to have less on average yeah
because they've had to put up with more
history and so you end up with a racial
disparity but I don't see if the how you
know that being said
I don't see how the solution is
affirmative action or racializing I
completely agree yeah and that's why
affirmative action is it best to stop
Gap and you could argue maybe it makes
the World Slightly more fair and it
makes it worse well you could argue in a
consequential sense because personally
when I think who deserves to get this
spot into college who deserves to get
that job I think of how hard they've
worked what effort has been put in what
what is the in in a consequential sense
what is the income to outcome there and
affirmative action in some cases helps
in some cases it actually quite hurts
people when it comes to that especially
with the treatment of say for example
Asian immigrants in Los Angeles UCLA the
negative affirmative action points they
get because a lot of those students are
sent over here from wealthy families in
China and you get this really
complicated situation and ultimately we
can avoid all of this all of this and
I'd love to avoid all of this if we just
put more effort into addressing the
underlying racial disparities in this
country but nobody wants to do that
which which would be and and what what
real real anti-redlining policies and
reparations not on race it gets messy
but on class because if you're if you
were poor 100 years ago in white you had
it better than if you're poor hundred
years ago in Black for sure but there
are still issues you can fix across the
board and that way you don't get a lot
of really messy racial politics that
might otherwise have felt like what do
you do like you test people's blood you
know exactly yeah that gets really
really messy but nobody wants to do this
I mean Republicans Democrats neither of
them want to do this how do you feel
about oh sorry to interrupt man how do
you feel about Universal basic income
yeah I think so as a socialist my one
contention is my concern would be that
Universal basic income would
assist in perpetually commodifying the
standards of life I don't want people to
have the money necessarily to afford
medical care or food I want those things
to just be available to people with that
wealth maybe being divested to or
diverted to like luxury goods that sort
of stuff
um but I think that like right now in
this country this is me like picking
which two beautiful delectable fruits I
want to eat from a tree if we could get
UEI in this country done properly like a
good Ubi absolutely and that would go a
long way too to fixing the situation
poor folk are in so we got to we got two
routes to go I definitely want to talk
about Ubi socialism Etc but I want to
make sure because we were originally
talking about antifa and right-wing
violence so going back to what we were
talking about before
with with antifa on the far left we have
people engaged in violence consistently
uh I mean
I I mean if we look at the death count
but what does that I mean that doesn't
change the fact that someone gets bashed
over that with a brick sure but I think
that generally speaking if we're looking
to quantify the amount of violence done
by Any Given number of groups the fact
that we've had historic racial protests
in this country with Native involvement
at some of these protests and we have I
think we have one death and it was that
100 antifa guy who was in Portland I
believe well you had the security
security guard who shot the guy in the
face oh that guy was an antifa no no he
was just uh Bernie bro but he was yeah
sure but he was The Unofficial security
guard sure but he wasn't operating in
the capacity of like a revolutionary
protester he was there and I I don't
know the circumstance of the death but
he wasn't like black block
um you have that and the fact that
there's only been so and so Much Death
from these groups I think when we're
looking at over the past 10 years
hundreds of deaths from the far-right
groups indicates something whether that
indicates the far-right group uses more
lethal methods you know uh done supposed
to Bricks I'd be willing to bet that
antifa don't carry guns for the most
part except for that one guy right right
yeah every once in a while you know but
when you see a far-right militia group
these people are not carrying flags and
Bricks these people carry firearms but I
think that ultimately
discussions on stochastic violence are
distractions from greater systemic
violence that I think that we all need
to pay a greater level of attention I
think if you got the left and the right
in a room and talked about the opioid
crisis and pharmaceutical companies
they're gonna they're gonna agree yeah I
think I think generally agree with that
the problem for me is man these guys in
in Michigan I don't care what you want
to call them lock them up you know
they're plotting a kidnapping whatever
it is they're staking out some
governor's house the courts had already
won in Michigan that the the legislation
ruled she had she her powers were you
know they stripped her powers from her
the courts ruled unconstitutional and
then the AG said I will not enforce any
of her laws and these guys were plotting
what for what reason like the system we
built it worked and so these guys were
nuts they got caught the FBI stake them
out locked them up congratulations but
when we look at Portland when we look at
Seattle when we look at what happened in
Chicago in the Pacific Northwest we get
what is like 140 nights now that's a bit
unfair because it's it's it's simmered
down quite a bit but we had a sustained
period of about 90 or so days where it
was just Riot every single night
explosives being thrown and when these
people would get arrested for doing
things that were like serious you know
like we had cops who had like Burns Cuts
lesions
and well for sure but I mean if you're
if so so I'll get to that you have these
people getting arrested and then the D.A
Mike Schmidt says you're free to go so
it was so bad the state police said
what's the point of being here if
they're getting released as soon as we
arrest them and they laugh well Trump
came in and deputized them then later
deputized the police now the feds are
dealing with it so death is death is the
worst possible outcome and we have
Michael reinel who killed that Trump
supporter and that is extremely
horrifying and we didn't get Mass
national press coverage about it which
instance is this Michael Rhino the guy
in Portland who said we got him right
here and then he fired Two Shots we
don't know if it's horrifying because he
never lived to see trial he was murked
by by it was it was definitely
horrifying and it was definitely
horrifying he got killed death is
horrifying but I mean like we didn't
even get to see a trial there like right
then that's and that's something that
the right doesn't really experience by
the way too you know like you have uh
you like Fort Hood for example you know
you treat these people with kid gloves
but that guy that guy outside the house
apparently according to like a bunch of
eyewitness testimony and the conflicting
narratives of the police who were there
he didn't draw a gun they just saw him
well I'll tell you this there's just
there's conflicting witness statements
but but only with minor variations the
vast majority of firm that the cop story
isn't true that that did not drive I I
read that there was a witness who said
they saw him drawing but I'll tell you
what it doesn't matter you know why
because uh uh even if we have witnesses
saying he did and he didn't Trump said
twice oh he he was at a rally he goes
they knew who he was and took him 15
minutes they didn't want to arrest him
and and the other time he said it was
retribution and that's that's yeah
that's messed up I'm trying to avoid
swearing I saw you tweet that by the way
when I saw it was I was yeah the
president claiming that we should just
get retribution about kill people no we
want that guy on trial so we can hear
everything about him and make sure we
know who he is we know what he's doing
we know why he's doing it to me to me it
shows to an extent fear as well if you
are confident in your case legally
speaking you want them to stand trial
because a trial is a years-long
prolonged shaming of them and everything
they represent right whereas them being
murdered martyrized them the only reason
you wouldn't want that is if you were
concerned that a trial would bring out
information or would it be inconvenient
to you in some way that that's why look
I think I'm not a big fan of trusting
the government but we've got a couple we
got a couple statements and it just
seems like inconclusive I'm not
inherently going to distrust the cops
who are there I'm not inherently going
to trust them either inconclusive is the
best you can ever get when it comes to
conflicting witness testimonies well so
so to my point
just because
sometimes one group of extremists kills
people doesn't mean we ignore the other
group of extremists oh I'm not arguing
that though I will defend I will defend
a lot of the the protest violence that's
been taking place
um I know and this is contended among a
lot of conservative circles but I think
an economist recently estimated that the
Damage Done to the black community in
this country could be monetarily
represented by a figure of like 14
trillion and that's one estimate of
course but it's just political I mean
how do you actually estimate well of
course you know there are different
methods and methodologies I'm not an
economist I can't fact check him I know
there are lower estimates as well but we
we know this you know uh in in the
United States of America for the longest
time the Western reaches of this country
they didn't have roads and they didn't
have electricity and they didn't have
phone lines and through an enormous
expenditure of federal wealth we put
effort into
um bringing that infrastructure Westwood
because the investment brings about more
educated people encourages uh the
development of more land which allows
for more people to live there which
means more money and we're facing now
the same issue albeit in a much more
sufficient sophisticated way with a lot
of poor communities in this country a
lot of which are black or Latino where
we now know these communities are black
holes of wealth people will make fun of
this like why give money to the schools
the black hole we could invest we could
prevent that from being a problem but
there are more poor white people than
poor black people sure and we and we
should invest absolutely right but there
are specific elements of black poverty
to to be fair I think you already said
reparations on class not race anyway
yeah so I yeah I get it there are some
there are some elements that are heavily
racialized there are studies for example
about the criminal justice system where
that are non-sensationalized like just
flat out the likelihood of given charges
or what your sentence will be even if
every other factor is accounted for just
races left and then you have things like
implicit bias but those things are
cultural shifts I don't think we can fix
that with law I certainly don't want
there to be like a federal mandate all
judges must give black men 10 lower
sentences to compensate for the racism
we assume they have but when it comes to
non-cultural issues like that the
deficit we see in these black
communities this is something worth
protesting and I think for a lot of
people people who grow up there this is
something worth fighting for I don't
think it's good to drive a car through
cops I don't think it's good to hurt
police officers but I recognize that
riots and violence at protests just seem
to be an inevitable product of great
civil strife and to me the solution to
this would be to say what can we do to
alleviate that Strife arrest people but
giving giving them what they want just
justifies their tactics well what do
they want honestly I don't know well I
mean the black lives matter on their
website they want to disrupt the nuclear
family they did remove it healthy food
man it's a class war being subsidized
we're talking no no dude we're talking
specifically about what the protesters
are asking for their lives no they don't
I mean dude chill they're not yes what
have they asked for specifically
or the the the the specific organization
because they tend to operate there's
there's no cohesive of ask well that's
always the way I mean you were an Occupy
Wall Street you know there's but there
were a few General asks Occupy Wall
Street had yeah and it was and it was a
lot of leftist stuff like healthcare
Transit schools
but that was a big problem with occupy
for sure yeah well we have I mean there
are fairly specific requests we do have
of course police reform which I think is
best represented in its most moderate
form by Joe Biden's policies I think
what's it called I I'm actually blanking
right now it's like eight main policies
that have been scientifically proven to
improve police well there's a name for
it yeah there's like I don't know yeah
well whatever the case is that's great
that's fine but then you have other
things like reinvestment back in the
community that's what defund the police
is mostly about terrible slogan Optics
wise mind you but defund the police
where does that money go you know not to
politicians Pockets hopefully it would
go back towards stuff like social work
or towards investment in education or
people forget about this uh Waste
Management you know these parts of these
cities are absolutely filthy it means
nobody wants to go outside travel to
businesses or work outside which means
that here's here's why here's what I
disagree I think uh if people aren't
motivated to serve their own communities
I don't think any amount of money is
going to change that and I think it
actually could make a bigger problem so
we we had are you familiar with Scott
Pressler
you'll have to uh he's blocked me on the
head he's this uh Trump supporting guy
who goes around cleaning up
that's about it cleans up so uh that's
awesome he went to LA he went to
Baltimore literally cleaning like
literally cleaning yeah yeah so he
brings a bunch of and a bunch of trump
supporters come out and they'll just
start cleaning things up and he actually
got smeared in the media for this like
they said his real motivations were to
like help Trump or whatever and I'm like
okay you know like carry on cleaning up
do you think there's an element of that
that could be true under certain
conditions like what if just
hypothetically I'm just curious before
you go on like what if it had been like
he'd go to Black communities that's what
he's doing right and he'd clean up he'd
be like see how easy it is you know and
now I'll clean up and get like the
picture you know and and to me and to me
it would it would feel almost like a
more patronizing you know like when the
white evangelicals go to Africa to help
build one house over three months or
something like that I actually think I'm
just asking I don't know the
circumstances I'm just curious I I I
don't think so but I think you
absolutely could make that argument and
you can make the exact same argument for
the fact that black lives matter is
overwhelmingly white to have a bunch of
white people claiming they're
representing the minorities there's one
viral video where it's like two white
anti for women are spray painting and
two black women are yelling at him to
stop and they're like no we're doing
this for you
like I don't I don't defend that right
the white participation at these rallies
I think is a good thing I think it
supports my argument that broadly
speaking this is a fight for a sort of
plurality of social justice rather than
a hyper-specific race war but it's not
popular like so so the general movement
has right now according to Civics in the
polling 48 approval then you've got 39
opposition and then 11 like unaffiliated
that's the Civics numbers that's other
than the Civil Rights Movement was it
well well so so black lives matter as a
general movement when you don't get into
the specifics you don't talk about the
protests regular people just say oh I
like that idea
um but 48 so it's not a majority it was
after George Floyd but they lost
ridiculous amount of support after the
riots heated up but to be fair and again
I just as as a person who's very
critical of the narratives media tries
to push to us how much of this is
because the movement functionally
changed and how much of it is because of
the hyper targeted media coverage of all
the violence to the exclusion of again
for every person who dies at a BLM
protest a hundred black people die of
covid a hundred black people die of
malnutrition or of gang violence or of
other issues that can be fixed through
the systemic solutions that black lives
matter people tend to support I I agree
with you I think the media is garbage in
this country and I think it's an issue
of human behaviors and the incentives of
the media machine as it exists that's
capitalism baby I got a socialism pill
yet it is and no no no I was talking to
some Trump support a couple years ago
and I said I'm for a mixed economy I
want regulation on these companies and
these three it was three guys there
Trump supporters they were like we think
that's wrong and I I said I I do not
believe in coercive Force physical force
and manipulative forced to to make
people do things and they asked me what
I meant by manipulative force and I was
like tricking people fraud and they were
like no no no if you convince someone to
exchange something for whatever that
that's their choice and I was like I'm
talking about the media lying to
everybody all the time and it's and
they're allowed to do it so the problem
is I believe in free speech they're
allowed to do it that's what it is I
just don't think it's ethical the way
our our media machines function like
this and I don't think there's a way to
solve for that problem because you can't
put someone in charge of what's
acceptable speech of course you end up
with media machines designed to make
people go crazy and I gotta be fair I
think there's criticism you can point
towards me for that absolutely because I
have my personal biases and the things I
don't like and I think if you look at
this is why I'm actually okay with
YouTubers like whether you're left right
or whatever like for you for instance
your socialist YouTuber like we clearly
have disagreements but you're one dude
by all means make all the videos you
want saying you know Trump is awful and
you know all the Republicans and I'll
and I'll talk about what I what I don't
like and I don't like you know
intersectionality and and democrats for
the current iteration of the Democrats
for sure about that intersectionality
thing by the way for sure when we get to
that of course yeah yeah
I think YouTube creates a space where
individuals will be like here's my world
as I see it hear the things I have
problems with the thing about these
these these companies is that they
editorially choose to hyper Target and
ignore things so to go back to your
point
they'll never talk about the opioid
crisis I mean they will like a little
bit but they're not going to be alive
today another x amount of people it's
just whenever it's convenient and
shocking and politically advantageous
for like an election cycle for instance
so to to basically say yes the media is
trash I think when it comes to what we
saw the riots they kept calling it
peaceful and they kept making excuses
for everything some did there's that
very highly publicized clip of the guy
saying despite some fires mostly
peaceful well like so that I I will say
absolutely hilarious
um not great I don't know if that's
representative of the general coverage I
do think for example that a lot of it
was necessary to push back on the
narrative that like cities were burning
I hear this phrase all the time Portland
burning Seattle burning nothing's one or
two buildings in a block on a
sporadically once in a week that's not
good I'm not of course but when you use
it but there is a reason why that
hyperbole is employed and it's not just
a rhetorical flourish it's to give the
person the impression that these cities
are actually collapsing
of course not true I've been to Portland
but have you have you seen all these
small towns that had those problems that
are struggling to recover because
they're right like when you have a small
town uh Michael Tracy traveled to these
places journalists he went around to a
bunch of small towns that people didn't
care about or know about because they're
not going to get National coverage and
they had widespread lootings and were
putting things on their doors like we
support black lives matter please don't
hurt us yeah yeah that's terrible but
their recovery is like it's it's not
going to happen because they're a small
town that money doesn't exist right but
I mean there is nothing I would propose
that wouldn't try to solve that I mean
the death of small town America has been
one of the greatest like demographic
crises that we've we don't even care
about small town America anymore in
anything other than a folksy aphorism we
can use to drum up voters when it comes
to actual investment we don't do
anything about these communities and the
way our businesses consolidate makes it
easier and easier for everyone to just
live in big cities yep I live in a big
city I like living in a big city I would
like it if people could choose between
that or more Rural Life without knowing
they will have fewer opportunities in
the latter at least severely hampered
opportunities but with regards to that
like the we support BLM please don't you
know loot us looting's illegal I'm not
defending um looting or I don't think
most Beyond people are defending looting
you just said you know there's a book
called in defense of looting and I think
it was the new was it the new Republic
it was written by a I think it was a
trans activist black lives matter and
this is coming from an article that may
have been I don't think it's the new
Republic but uh so uh this is this is
all stems for where like I started
getting more upset with this level of
activism because I've been covering
civil unrest but that's not broadly
representative you know you said it
yourself those two like black women
trying to keep the two white people from
spray painting when I see videos of
these protests one of the first things
they teach you if you protest
consistently and I used to protest more
um before I decided I hated going
outside and that I didn't like being uh
you know sunburned was that um you you
want to minimize negative engagement
with the community that you're in
looting arson tagging these things the
definition of negatively affecting but
they defend it well who because people
keep saying they they defended a book or
activist sure some media calling it
peaceful over and over again I mean
there's like most of the protests were
peaceful though like a vast majority but
what does that mean most well like
that's the joke we make mostly peaceful
97 93. so it's 90 well but there's the
and that's a tricky statistic too
because at seven percent of all the BLM
rallies you know there was violence who
started that violence they you're based
in coppelled I know you know cops will
regularly initiate violence against
protesters either by putting one of
their own amongst their rank throwing a
rock and then using it as justification
or by just starting themselves we have
plenty of video and uh data based
evidence to defend that but that's
that's not enough to indict the officers
in specific places no no but I'm just
saying so only seven percent of these
protests had violence but we don't know
how much of that was actually protester
initiated violence and even of those
that were how much it was like one or
two guys we don't know most of these
protests were peaceful the data on that
is very clear but that's that's that's
that's fine we're arguing over margins
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification Bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all next time